first of all i cannot believe you're
here which i just said to you in the
hall
i mean you just had a baby five minutes
ago i i literally just had a baby like
30 days ago it's wild
you went from hospital gown to valentino
gown
in one month pushing 3.5 hours yes
what a year have you had a moment to
stop and think here you are at the first
grammy nomination
first baby all in this very small span
of time you know i've had a lot of time
to think about it
because we are you know we're stuck at
home but
having this baby this beautiful baby boy
that i had has taken a lot of
that pressure off of me i guess and i've
just been
just so involved in him like that's
really all that matters to me right now
but this grammy is
amazing like i still can't believe it
it's so
wild and i'm just so thankful i didn't
quit
and that really is like truly a true
testament that like
when you have a dream that is so
important for you no matter how hard it
gets you cannot quit
because if it if i quit none of this
would have happened yep
and i've wanted too many times and i'm
just so grateful i didn't that i stuck
with it
and i became true to who i really am if
you think
we live in the land of the free
you should try to be
what do you think it is about
you the song the new song that people
have gravitated to
during such a hard time in our world
you know the world stopped and it forced
us to really look at ourselves but i
wrote this song
like almost three years ago after i saw
botham jean
and that story of how he passed away i
wrote this song after that
and i was so affected by that and i've
seen police brutality happen against my
husband
and just now the world stopped and was
able to see it
and to see us and to see what is truly
truly important that we are all one
that we're all we have the same blood
and that we need to be respectful and
love each other like really love each
other that's so important
i think you being here at this grammys
is so important in 2021
for so many reasons number one love the
fierce female power
that is on this grammy stage this year
it's so important women
are so important women in country music
are so important and so often
we're not made to feel like we're
important and
for us to be on that stage together is
going to be so powerful
so powerful you are a trailblazer though
um in so many ways but what does it mean
to you i mean i'm just thinking of the
week we've had the meghan markle
interview morgan's record's been number
one after
what he said i mean this is the hate
that i got after i called it out it was
really bad
i mean really bad for you yeah it caused
me to go into early labor
it did no way the stress
yeah the stress like the day before i
gave birth i was
literally in bed clinging to my mom and
my husband
because of how horrible it was yeah and
it's very interesting because someone
said something this morning after the
megan interview and they said you know
people are more upset
about you calling out the racism than
they are about the racism
and what does that mean it says a lot
it says a lot that we have a lot of work
to do
because i didn't do anything wrong
and here you are and she didn't do
anything wrong by calling it out but yet
the hate that you get back for that it's
insane
and so how do you move forward how do
you keep pushing yourself and as your
star grows you're going to be
in the public eye more and more
inclusion and lifting each other up
really is the key for me yeah and
opening that door not only banging on
that door for myself but holding that
door open for others no matter who that
is
holding that door open and really
lifting each other up that's what 2021
is to me and it is not enough
that i'm the only black woman signed to
a major record label in nashville there
needs to be
several black women signed to major
record companies in nashville
and it's so important like even the
lbgtqia plus community there's so many
artists that are finally
coming out and saying this is who i am
and
you have to accept me for who i am and
that's what it's all about is love and
acceptance and that's how we make it
work
you must be excited to have a child
coming into what the next 10 years of
this world will look like
this is exciting how do you think
motherhood will
change music will change touring will
change honky tonks
it changes everything like literally
even me being here
and interviewing with you he's all i
think about and i just want the world to
be better for him
so that he doesn't have to go through
what i went through and what many of us
go through the pain that we've gone
through i don't want him to have to go
through that so
i'm gonna fight for that